we are back with the one and only Jim
Gaffigan from the new Disney plus movie
Peter Pan and Wendy let's talk about
that
Jude Law is Captain Hook
um it's it's one of those it looks like
it has the largest budget it is it's
just budget stunning built a huge pirate
ship it's stunning yeah it's crazy it's
fun like they leap off the clock the
special effects oh yeah it's a beautiful
David Lowry who did who's an amazing
Dragon yeah
um
[Applause]
one of uh my favorite people to ever
come here Yara Shahidi is Tinkerbell oh
yeah
[Applause]
um all right we have a few dad jokes in
here
um to rank the dad jokes on a scale of
one to five are three real life dads
there's Alan Randall
and yes sir by the way can I point out
can I point that point out that they all
have beards oh and you know why men have
men that have beards they have beards
because at one point they looked in the
mirror of their face and said
I gotta grow a beard
you know what's fun I didn't like facial
hair as a kid I thought it was so weird
and I love it now oh right bring on a
stash a chop a something
um so I think you all look very handsome
um okay will you read the first dad joke
first uh I did not know this
um all right no one ever talks about
Peter Pan's brother Peter Potts
I haven't looked at these either by the
way are these fresh to you these are
fresh these are I mean I don't know if I
would call this fresh but
all right dads what do you think
three two out of what how many right all
right out of five all right all right
okay uh how come Peter Pan is always
flying because he never lands
Berg oh oh yeah I'm sure but I I think I
feel like that just ranked High because
of like the tie into the movie yeah I
don't know or because you're better
yeah
all right here did you hear the rumor
about butter
well I'm not going to spread it
that's oh look at
the five
oh my gosh I think that's our highest
score yeah I love dad jokes because the
reason dads do dad jokes is to make the
children unhappy
right it's the fact that the kids it's
the fact that they're so bad that they
annoy a child brings joy to a older man
I know well I it does the same for women
because every time they're like Mom
you're embarrassing I'm like right
okay how many tickets does it take to
make an octopus laugh
oh sorry how many tickles does it take
to make an octopus laugh
ten tickles
[Music]
that one got a high school that was good
it's all you know what we're all we're
gonna do this for the next hour
well I wanted to say thank you for
helping us launch this show
and I know that you're a fan of David
Copperfield oh my gosh thank you so much
that is
um a royal collector's edition wow thank
you so much don't I look smart
oh my gosh that's so nice of you
stream Peter Pan and Wendy starting
Friday April 28th on Disney plus and Jim
Gaffigan thank you because what I find
funny in this world and in this life is
you thank you
I'll be right back
[Music]